floating on the Mediterranean Sea this
castle protected an ancient port city
for hundreds of years it's also a place
shrouded in myth where a legendary
princess met a certain fate just about
700 feet off the coast of southern
Turkey the Kiska lazy or maidens Castle
sits on an island so tiny it looks like
it's standing on water the walls and
towers of the castle date back to the
early 12th century although exactly who
built it is a mystery according to one
legend a Byzantine King built the castle
after a fortune-teller told him that his
only daughter would die from a snakebite
despite the king's efforts to protect
the princess a snake snuck in by hiding
in a fruit basket and the princess met
her unfortunate fate fortified walls
wrap around the entire complex with
eight towers providing 360-degree views
making the castle an effective first
line of defense against enemy ships
approaching the port The Legend of the
12th century may be a thing of the past
but the stone walls of the fortress
still stand today keeping their secrets
[Music]